I'm like it's la is incredibly lonely
and can be very very lonely because it's
unlike a city like I feel like in New
York it's there's a different vibe or
you could be for instance acting in a
play and then doing something to pay the
rent maybe you're waiting tables or
whatever it's not quite a soul-crushing
there's not quite as harsh of a judgment
laid upon you and maybe an actor is
going to disagree with me but I feel
like in LA there's so much pressure put
on this perception of your success that
people don't open up about how scared
they are about money and so they just
they go and they just hobble away you
just drive up to your little place you
open the door you go inside and then you
you sees people at meetings everyone has
general generally just a nod your head
and smile it's fine it's fine